So Neil Chesanow, do you have a copy of your book, Please Read This for Me, there with you?
那么，尼尔·切萨诺，你手边有你的书《请代我读此书》吗？
Yes, I do, right in my greasy little claw.
有的，就在我这双油腻腻的小爪子里。
Perfect. Can I ask you to open up just to the opening page of the preface to read from the preface?
太好了。能请你翻到序言的第一页，给大家读一下序言吗？
"When you have something very important but really tough to tell the man in your life, wouldn't it be great if you could just reach for a book that starts the conversation for you? Imagine being able to turn to the appropriate page, give an open book to the man you love, and ask, 'Please read this for me.' 'What is it?' 'Just read it, OK? Page 73. It's only a few lines.'
“当你有什么非常重要但又难以启齿的事情要告诉生命中的那个男人时，要是能随手拿起一本书，替你开启这段对话，那该多好？试想一下，当你翻到适当的那一页，把翻开的书递给你爱的男人，对他说：‘请代我读读这个。’‘是什么？’‘读就对了，好吗？第73页，就几行字。’
Once the man you love has the book in his hands, a glance will do the job. Each page is an emotional telegram."
一旦你爱的男人拿到这本书，只需一眼，任务就完成了。每一页都是一封情感电报。”
Neil Chesanow's book is now long out of print. But back in the 1980s, when it was published, it represented, I think, a kind of utopian endgame for what self-help books could accomplish. Instead of explaining in a general way how you should handle this situation or that situation in your life, the book, Please Read This to Me, cut to the chase, went to the next logical step. It actually gave you a script. You're in this situation? Say this. Here are the actual words you can use to kick off the conversation you need to have.
尼尔·切萨诺的这本书早已绝版。但回想上世纪80年代它刚出版时，我认为它代表了自助类书籍所能实现的某种乌托邦式的终极目标。这本书没有泛泛地解释你该如何处理生活中这样或那样的情况，而是直击要害，迈出了合乎逻辑的下一步。它实际上是给了你一份剧本。你处于这种状况？那就这么说。这里有你可以直接用来开启对话的现成词句。
I tried to come up with a book that would not just tell you how to communicate, but actually spark conversation.
我试图创作一本书，不仅是告诉你如何沟通，更能真正地引发对话。
Let me just read some of these titles to give people a sense of what some of these are like. Page 111, "It's time to admit you don't have a drinking problem. You're an alcoholic." Page 82, "You act like Cary Grant in public and Archie Bunker at home." Page 134, "I think about marriage all the time." Page 148, "Maybe I'm not ready to have a baby." Page 136, "You'd probably prefer if I were an orphan." Let me ask you to read the one on page 135.
让我读一下其中的一些标题，让大家感受一下它们是什么样的。第111页，“是时候承认你没有酗酒问题了。你是个酒鬼。”第82页，“你在公共场合表现得像加里·格兰特，在家却像阿奇·邦克。”第134页，“我一直在考虑结婚的事。”第148页，“也许我还没准备好要孩子。”第136页，“你大概宁愿我是一个孤儿。”让我请你读一下第135页的那篇。
OK. This one is entitled, "It could be that I'm falling out of love." A difficult subject. "Once I thought I loved you. Now I'm not so sure. Yes, we've changed over time, but that's only part of it. I feel confused. I don't know what I feel.
好的。这一篇的标题是，“也许我正对你失去爱意。”一个沉重的话题。“曾经，我以为我爱你。现在，我不再那么确定了。是的，随着时间的推移我们都变了，但这只是其中一部分原因。我感到困惑。我不知道自己的感受。
One minute I say to myself, stick it out. Make it work. Don't be a quitter. And I feel guilty. It's not in my power to change you. That much I've learned. So I'm giving some serious thought to the only alternative left that I can think of-- a trial separation. If you have another suggestion, I'd like to hear it."
一分钟前我对自己说，坚持下去。让这段感情继续。别做个逃兵。然后我感到内疚。改变你并不在我的能力范围内。这一点我学到了。所以我正在认真考虑我能想到的唯一选择——分居试验。如果你有其他建议，我很乐意听听。”
Over and over in this book, Chesanow and his co-author, Gareth Esersky, take some of the most painful situations that people can have with each other and give surprisingly graceful one-minute speeches that a person could say or write or show to somebody else. There are a dozen about problems that people might have together in bed. 10 are about dealing with each other as friends. 10 are about the fights that couples have over money. One of the entries even ends with the sentence, "Let's become husband and wife." All of these are written for women because, Chesanow says, men don't buy these books.
切萨诺和他的合著者加雷斯·埃瑟斯基在书中一遍又一遍地选取人们之间最痛苦的处境，并给出令人惊讶的优雅的一分钟演讲，让人们可以对别人说出、写下或展示出来。其中有十几篇关于人们在床上可能遇到的问题。有10篇是关于如何作为朋友相处。有10篇是关于夫妻间因金钱产生的争吵。其中一篇甚至以“让我们成为夫妻吧”这句话结尾。所有这些都是为女性写的，因为切萨诺说，男人不买这些书。
We specifically interviewed women to come up with the most difficult kinds of subjects to discuss.
我们专门采访了女性，总结出最难讨论的各种话题。
Let me ask you to read another one.
让我请你再读一篇。
I'd be happy to.
我很乐意。
Let me ask you to read on page 105.
让我请你读一下第105页。
This one is titled, "Let's Get Religion." "There's something missing in our lives. We're so focused on relating to each other that we've overlooked an important aspect of relating to our world. I'm talking about religion, spirituality, God. A belief in God and a spiritual life can add--"
这一篇的标题是，“让我们信教吧。”“我们的生活中缺少了什么。我们太专注于彼此之间的关系，却忽略了与世界建立联系的一个重要方面。我说的是宗教、灵性、上帝。对上帝的信仰和精神生活可以增加——”
When you read one of these after another, the book as a whole seems to have this almost touching faith in the idea that getting the words right might actually solve something or help something. But of course, if you want religion in your life and your partner doesn't, or if you think you've fallen out of love, or if you don't want a baby and your spouse does, I've got to say, your main problem is not what words to use. Your main problem is the situation itself. Neil Chesanow says that plenty of times he heard from women who used the words in the book and it didn't fix the problem.
当你一篇接一篇地读这些内容时，整本书似乎有一种近乎感人的信念，认为只要措辞正确，或许真的能解决或改善某些问题。但当然，如果你想要宗教信仰而你的伴侣不想要，或者如果你认为自己已经不再相爱，或者如果你不想要孩子而你的配偶想要，我必须说，你的主要问题不在于使用什么词汇。你的主要问题是处境本身。尼尔·切萨诺说，他曾多次听到那些使用了书中词句的女性反馈，结果问题并没有得到解决。
So there may not be magic words. There aren't always magic words, but sometimes that in itself becomes something vital for a woman to understand. Now she can tell herself, well, I really have given it my best shot. This message in Please Read This for Me really sums up my feelings. He's still not willing to respond. I think we're reaching one of those landmark moments where we have to decide whether we want to go on or not.
所以，可能根本就没有什么魔法词汇。魔法词汇并不总是存在，但有时这本身就成了女性需要理解的重要一点。现在她可以告诉自己，好吧，我已经尽我所能了。《请代我读此书》中的这段话确实总结了我的感受。他仍然不愿意回应。我想我们正到达一个标志性的时刻，必须决定我们是否还要继续走下去。
Which brings us to today's radio program. Today, during this week in which talking is failing on an international level, from Washington and Moscow to Paris and Baghdad, we bring you stories that ask the question, what is talking good for, anyway? When does it work? When doesn't it work? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in four acts.
这就引出了今天的广播节目。在谈话在国际层面上遭遇挫折的这一周里，从华盛顿到莫斯科，再到巴黎和巴格达，我们为你带来了一些故事，探讨一个问题：谈话到底有什么用？它什么时候有效？什么时候无效？这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为四个篇章。
Act One, How to Write a Note. In that act, a guy who thinks that words and reason might help his friend from trying to hurt himself. Act Two, The Battle of Words Versus Fear. In that act, one man decides to conquer his fears by listing them, all of them, one after another, all 183 of them.
第一章，如何写便条。在那一章里，一个人认为言语和理性能帮助他的朋友打消伤害自己的念头。第二章，言语与恐惧之战。在那一章里，一个人决定通过列出自己的恐惧来战胜它们，所有这些恐惧，一个接一个，总共183个。
Act Three, When a City Opens Its Big Mouth. The story of just how easy-- how astonishingly easy-- it is to get people of all ages and races and economic levels to open up and chat. You just need three little words. Act Four, Wedding Bells and Telephone Bells. In that act, Jonathan Goldstein and Liz Gilbert bring us stories of words failing-- in one case, in the worst wedding toast that any of us has ever heard of occurring at a real wedding. Stay with us.
第三章，当城市张开大嘴。这个故事讲述了让所有年龄、种族和经济阶层的人敞开心扉聊天是多么容易——多么令人震惊的容易。你只需要三个小词。第四章，婚礼的钟声与电话的铃声。在那一章里，乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和利兹·吉尔伯特为我们带来了关于言语失效的故事——其中一个案例是，我们所听说过的在真实婚礼上发生的最糟糕的婚礼祝酒词。请继续收听。
Act One, How to Write a Note.
第一章，如何写便条。
This first story on our show today is unusual. It wasn't originally made to be broadcast on any radio show. It was a tape made by somebody who had never put anything together for radio. He made it to give to a friend. Here's what happened.
今天节目中的第一个故事非常不寻常。它原本不是为了在任何广播节目中播出而制作的。这是一盘录音带，由一个从未为广播做过任何内容的人制作。他制作它是为了送给一个朋友。事情是这样的。
Back in July of 1999, Jake Warga heard that somebody who he was close to in college, his friend Brian, tried to kill himself. Jake went out to visit Brian and he took with him this little MiniDisc recorder that he had just bought for himself that had this little clip-on microphone. During his visit with Brian, they recorded this long conversation they had. And then when Jake got home, he decided to edit this down and give it to Brian as a present.
1999年7月，杰克·瓦尔加听说他在大学时的一位挚友布莱恩试图自杀。杰克去探望布莱恩，随身带着他刚给自己买的一个小型迷你光盘录音机，上面还带着一个小夹式麦克风。在探望布莱恩期间，他们录下了那场长谈。杰克回家后，决定将其剪辑成片，作为礼物送给布莱恩。
He had no idea how to actually edit sound or do anything like that, so at some point, he jumped onto the internet and found a website-- a website, actually, that we've mentioned on our show in the past, called transom.org that teaches beginners how to edit and mix audio with links to free editing software. And Jake put together this story you're about to hear. And he sent it to Brian. His hope was that if Brian heard this tape, heard himself talking, heard his own words, it might convince him that he shouldn't try to kill himself again. That didn't work. Here's the tape that Jake put together.
他根本不知道该如何剪辑声音，也不知道怎么做这些事，所以他在某个时候上网找到了一个网站——事实上，这个网站我们以前在节目中提到过，叫transom.org，它教初学者如何剪辑和混合音频，并附有免费剪辑软件的链接。杰克整理出了你即将听到的这个故事。他把它发给了布莱恩。他的希望是，如果布莱恩听到这盘录音带，听到自己的声音，听到自己的话语，或许能让他相信不应该再试图自杀。但这没起作用。以下是杰克整理出来的录音带。
Last year, my friend Brian tried to commit suicide. He had checked himself into a new hotel that runs alongside the interstate, which happens to pass through the small college town in which he lives. And without ceremony or note-writing, he took a combination of drugs he thought sufficient enough to quietly end his life.
去年，我的朋友布莱恩试图自杀。他在州际公路旁的一家新旅馆开了房，这条公路恰好经过他居住的大学城。他没有举行任何仪式，也没有留下便条，而是服用了一种他认为足以让他静静结束生命的药物组合。
As people often do, Brian and I started getting lazy about communicating after I left college and moved out of that same college town. Emails became rare, and phone calls rarer. After the longest period yet of not hearing from Brian, I got a call from an old mutual friend of ours asking if I had seen or heard from him. I said I had not.
就像人们常做的那样，我离开大学并搬出那个大学城后，布莱恩和我开始疏于沟通。电子邮件变得稀少，电话更少。在经历了我与布莱恩失联最长的一段时间后，我接到了我们一位老朋友的电话，问我是否见过或听过他的消息。我说没有。
We made calls and eventually found him safe in the hospital. A few weeks later, I arranged a visit to see how my old school-- and Brian-- had changed in the years I had been away. And when I came to visit, we sat for three hours on a park bench late one summer night. He was still in the process of piecing together exactly what had happened. This is Brian.
我们拨打了电话，最终发现他在医院里很安全。几周后，我安排了一次访问，想看看我离开的这些年里，我的母校——以及布莱恩——发生了什么变化。当我去看望他时，在一个夏天的深夜，我们在公园的长椅上坐了三个小时。他当时仍在整理到底发生了什么。这是布莱恩。
Let's talk about you.
我们谈谈你吧。
There's not much to talk about.
没什么好谈的。
You were going to go to the hospital today, right?
你今天要去医院，对吧？
Oh, yeah. I did. Yeah. The woman in the records department made a photocopy of my medical records from when I got admitted, and there wasn't anything too surprising or anything in there. But it was still interesting to read. But they said I was discovered at approximately 6:00 PM. I guess this was the next day.
哦，是的。我去了。病案科的女士复印了我入院时的病历，里面没有什么太令人惊讶的内容。但读起来还是很有趣。他们说我大约在下午6点被发现。我想这是第二天了。
6:00 PM?
下午6点？
Yeah. I don't know why--
是的。我不知道为什么——
They waited so long?
他们等了那么久？
Yeah. Because I should have checked out around noon, I guess. But they said I was unconscious and unresponsive. I was reading the paramedics report. I was pale, cold, and clammy, and I was breathing only six respirations per minute, which is very slow.
是的。因为我想我本应该在中午左右退房的。但他们说我当时处于昏迷且无反应状态。我在读急救人员的报告。我脸色苍白、身体冰冷湿冷，呼吸只有每分钟六次，非常缓慢。
And they said they found pill bottles and a bottle of alcohol in the room. And they cleared my airway and started administering oxygen. Then they gave me a 2 milliliters IV of something called Narcan, which is an antidote for opiates like morphine.
他们说在房间里发现了药瓶和一瓶酒。他们清理了我的呼吸道并开始供氧。然后他们给我静脉注射了2毫升名为纳洛酮的药物，这是吗啡等阿片类药物的解毒剂。
Do you think it would have worked?
你觉得这奏效了吗？
I think it would have. And I mean, maybe I didn't take enough because morphine is very serious. It's very hard core. It's very easy to OD on it. (JOKINGLY) It's hard core, man. And I guess it was really late that night or even early the next morning when I guess they were about to transfer me, and I woke up. And the attendant who wrote this report said that I said I was disappointed to be alive and that I had passed out before I could take the morphine.
我觉得奏效了。我的意思是，也许我服用的量不够，因为吗啡非常严重。它是硬核的。服用过量非常容易。（开玩笑地说）这很硬核，伙计。我想那是那天深夜甚至是第二天清晨，他们准备转院时我醒了。写这份报告的护理员说我当时表示很失望自己还活着，而且我在服用吗啡之前就已经昏过去了。
And that part I do remember really vaguely. I remember waking up and feeling the nasal cannula in my nose giving me oxygen and seeing that IV bottle hovering over me. And the guy asked me, kind of sarcastically it sounded, so are you glad to be alive? And I'm pretty sure I remember saying no.
那部分我记得非常模糊。我记得醒来时感觉到鼻导管在给我供氧，看到那瓶静脉注射液悬在上方。那个人问我，听起来有点讽刺，问我是不是很高兴还活着？我很确定我记得我说不。
Brian doesn't have that many friends. He's good-looking and funny, yet something inside prevents him from being confident in social skills. For example, it took a long time in our friendship before he told me, and I felt confident in asking, about his biological mother. He told me she died when he was young, that she had committed suicide. His father remarried soon after and raised Brian and his brother, who is now a doctor.
布莱恩没几个朋友。他长得帅又风趣，但内心深处有什么东西阻碍了他建立社交自信。例如，在我们的友谊持续很长一段时间后，他才告诉我关于他亲生母亲的事，而我也才感到有把握去问。他告诉我，她在他小时候就去世了，她是自杀身亡的。他父亲不久后改组了家庭，抚养大了布莱恩和他的哥哥，现在哥哥是一位医生。
Although, there seemed to be some incongruities with the reports. I guess those paramedics and hospital staff can really hastily fill stuff out. They can really take a lot of license. My own mom's coroner's report was really-- it had some gross inconsistencies in it, or errors. My brother says coroners often just make stuff up if they can't find certain causes, like cause of death, I guess.
尽管报告中似乎存在一些矛盾之处。我想那些急救人员和医务人员填表时确实很匆忙。他们确实能动用很大的自由裁量权。我母亲的验尸报告真的很——它有一些严重的出入或错误。我哥哥说，如果验尸官无法确定某些死因，他们往往只是瞎编。
Were you hoping to find similarities between your mom's report and your report?
你当时是希望能从你母亲的报告和你的报告中找到相似之处吗？
Oh, no. I hadn't really thought of that. I brought her up just because they made some errors on hers, just like they had with mine. But with me, I don't think it was anything really major.
哦，不。我没往那方面想。我提到她只是因为她的报告上有错误，就像他们在我身上犯错一样。但对我来说，我不认为有什么真正重大的问题。
About a week prior to this interview, Brian was arrested in San Francisco for possession of narcotics. Brian does not use drugs or alcohol. He had gone to the same bad part of town to buy the same drugs with the intent of trying again. I asked him about this trip to San Francisco.
在这次采访前大约一周，布莱恩在旧金山因持有毒品被捕。布莱恩不吸毒也不喝酒。他去过那个糟糕的城市街区，为了购买同样的药物，意图再试一次。我问了他这次旧金山之行。
What were you doing there?
你去那里干什么？
Same thing.
一样的事情。
Same cocktail?
同样的鸡尾酒疗法？
Mhm. Pretty much.
嗯。差不多。
But it didn't work before.
但之前没奏效。
I'm too much of a wimp to try other things, like other things that might be more violent but less immediate. I don't like violence in practice.
我太胆小了，不敢尝试其他东西，比如那些可能更暴力但不那么直接的方法。我不喜欢在实践中搞暴力。
I've read that suicide is a selfish act, yet I have never really thought of Brian as selfish. But I can understand why the relatives of suicide victims might go through that angry phase, that phase when they place the blame on the person who killed themselves to help with any feelings of guilt they might have. I asked Brian if he thought what he did was selfish.
我读过自杀是一种自私的行为，但我从来没觉得布莱恩自私。但我能理解为什么自杀受害者的亲属会经历那个愤怒的阶段，那个把责任归咎于自杀者以减轻内心愧疚感的阶段。我问布莱恩，他是否认为自己的行为是自私的。
I say it's selfish in the same sense that going to a therapist is selfish. You have a problem and you're doing something about it. You're doing something about it in the way you feel like coping with it.
我说它是自私的，就像去看心理医生是自私的一样。你遇到了问题，并且你在采取行动。你以你觉得能够应对它的方式在采取行动。
I don't think, in the end, people should live for other people. They should really live for themselves, just like you shouldn't go to school for a decade to become a doctor or a lawyer or whatever just because your parents want you to be that because you want to do what your parents want you to do. You should live your life as you want, as you see fit.
归根结底，我认为人们不应该为别人而活。他们应该真正为自己而活，就像你不应该为了迎合父母的意愿去读十年的医学院或法学院，只因为你想做父母想让你做的事。你应该按你想要的方式、按你认为合适的方式过你的生活。
And it doesn't necessarily mean you haven't considered other people's reactions. It just means that maybe you have and you've decided that, unfortunately, you still want to go forward with it. I don't want to spend the rest of my life alive and miserable just because someone else doesn't want me to die. I don't see much sense to that.
而且这并不一定意味着你没有考虑过其他人的反应。这只是意味着也许你考虑过了，但不幸的是，你仍然决定继续。我不想因为别人不希望我死，就余生都活在痛苦中。我觉得这没什么意义。
In an effort to catch up on letter-writing, Brian would occasionally write long emails filled with wit, humor, and sometimes desperation. He's an excellent writer. I asked him why he didn't write a suicide note.
为了弥补书信往来，布莱恩偶尔会写很长的电子邮件，充满机智、幽默，有时也充满绝望。他是个出色的作家。我问他为什么不写遗书。
I'll admit that was rather selfish. I know that people were wondering what the heck is up. I could have sat down for probably what would have been several hours to type something up. At that point in time, I was just very fed up and impatient and just I wanted it all to end. I just didn't want to screw around with anything else. I could've also cleaned my room first, too.
我承认那确实相当自私。我知道人们想知道到底发生了什么。我本可以坐下来，花上几个小时打点什么出来。但当时，我只是受够了，非常不耐烦，我只想这一切都结束。我不想再折腾任何事了。我也本可以先打扫一下房间。
As we were talking, an ambulance passed by in no particular hurry.
当我们交谈时，一辆救护车不紧不慢地驶过。
There's what I probably rode in. It cost over $800 to be transported from--
我大概就是坐这辆车走的。从那儿到这儿的运送费用超过800美元——
A few blocks?
几个街区？
Yeah. According to their time table, it took them eight minutes to get from there to there.
是的。按照他们的时间表，他们花八分钟从那儿到这儿。
I guess that's pretty far.
我想那挺远的。
Yeah, that's an appreciable distance, I guess. It's worth eight minutes. 2 milligrams, 2 tiny milligrams of Narcan opiate antidote is $6.
是的，那是一段相当长的距离。八分钟的时间确实值这个钱。2毫克，2小毫克的纳洛酮阿片类解毒剂只要6美元。
As I write this, I wonder if I'm making Brian's note for him. Am I documenting this story for him, or for whom he might leave behind? This was not the first time he tried committing suicide, and, in light of his recent arrest, not his last.
当我写下这些时，我在想我是否在替布莱恩写遗书。我是在为他记录这个故事，还是为了他离世后留下的那些人？这已经不是他第一次试图自杀，而且考虑到他最近被捕，这也不是最后一次。
Do you think you found the only way to cope?
你认为你找到了应对的唯一方法吗？
The only viable way, so to speak. I don't get the impression most people are that happy, anyway. They just grind their way through life. They'll have kids, and that'll give them an artificial reason to live for a while. And then the kids grow up and forget about them.
唯一可行的方法，可以这么说。反正我觉得大多数人也没那么快乐。他们只是在生活中苦苦挣扎。他们会有孩子，那会给他们一个暂时的、人为的活着的理由。然后孩子们长大了，就把他们忘了。
I know the mind is a really powerful thing. People can do just about anything they really put their minds to, but it also takes a tremendous amount of self-motivation. As my therapist says, it has to come from within, and it doesn't feel like there's much within.
我知道思想是非常强大的东西。人们只要下定决心，几乎可以做任何事，但这也需要巨大的自我激励。正如我的心理医生所说，它必须来自内心，而我感觉内心并没有多少东西。
What's your relationship with death?
你和死亡的关系是什么？
I was brought up in a Protestant family as a Lutheran, and I haven't renounced that faith. I just feel I've stumbled in a big way, and I haven't gotten up or haven't been able to get up. And I'm hoping that I'll just go to heaven after I die. But of course, there is a lingering fear of hell because it's not a-- it's highly stigmatized, suicide. But I don't think I believe in sins that are, what do you call them? Cardinal. Yeah. I think it's just another kind of sin.
我在一个信奉路德教的新教家庭中长大，我没有背弃那种信仰。我只是觉得我摔得很惨，还没能爬起来，或者说无法爬起来。我希望死后能去天堂。但当然，对地狱存在着挥之不去的恐惧，因为——自杀是被高度污名化的。但我认为我不相信有什么所谓的“大罪”。是的。我觉得那只是另一种罪。
My cousin, Amy, who's an atheist, told me that her dad, who's a Lutheran minister, told her that, if you kill yourself, you go to hell because you're not alive to repent and ask forgiveness for that sin. So therefore, since you have not repented for that sin, you'll go to hell.
我的表妹艾米是个无神论者，她告诉我，她父亲，一位路德教会的牧师，曾告诉她，如果你自杀，你会下地狱，因为你活着的时候没有忏悔并请求宽恕那种罪。所以，因为你没有为那种罪忏悔，你会下地狱。
And I think that's ridiculous. Just think of all the sins you haven't repented for in your life, even if you tried to. I know you haven't tried to, but-- so I do have a fear of dying, but it doesn't always outweigh my other fears or my other--
我认为这很荒谬。想想你一生中那些没有忏悔过的罪吧，即使你想忏悔。我知道你还没试过，但是——所以我确实有死亡的恐惧，但它并不总是盖过我其他的恐惧或——
Fear of living?
活着的恐惧？
Yeah.
是的。
After sitting at a park bench for so long, and after Brian confessed to having talked more than he ever has, we were more than overdue for a stretch. And after a while of walking around aimlessly, we picked up our old habit of trainspotting and penny-smashing.
在公园长椅上坐了那么久，在布莱恩承认说了比以往任何时候都多的话之后，我们早就该伸展一下筋骨了。在漫无目的地走了一会儿后，我们又恢复了旧习惯：看火车和压硬币。
[TRAIN WHISTLE BLOWING]
[火车汽笛声]
Jeez.
天哪。
Quick.
快。
I would have loved to--
我本希望——
You're taking it slow.
你跑得太慢了。
I probably shouldn't run with this thing. I don't know if I can record while being jostled.
我大概不应该拿着这东西跑。我不知道在颠簸的时候能不能录音。
It'll catch up.
它会跟上的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
We are now running to try to catch the train. We're running past lions. We're now up on the tracks. Here come the lights.
我们现在跑着试图赶上火车。我们跑过狮子像。我们现在跑到了铁轨上。灯光来了。
At this point, Brian and I are running alongside the train as it's beginning to stop at the nearby station.
此时，布莱恩和我正沿着火车跑，它开始在附近的车站停下。
[TRAIN RUNNING]
[火车行进声]
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
[TRAIN HALTING]
[火车停止声]
Well, train's here. No pennies.
好了，火车到了。没压到硬币。
Oh, brother. I have a penny or two.
噢，兄弟。我有一两枚硬币。
Give it up.
给吧。
You give it up, homeboy.
你给吧，伙计。
I don't know. Anything else?
我不知道。还有什么吗？
Do you ever cry?
你哭过吗？
No. I hardly remember the last time. It's probably been almost 10 years. I came close, though, in December of '92 when I came home after visiting my grandma over Christmastime. My grandma had shown us a bunch of pictures of my biological mom and told us some stories about her.
没有。我几乎不记得上一次是什么时候了。那大概是快10年前了。不过，1992年12月圣诞节期间我去探望祖母回到家时，我确实快哭了。我祖母向我们展示了一堆我亲生母亲的照片，并讲了一些关于她的故事。
These were photos I don't think I'd ever seen and stories I don't think I'd ever heard. I came home and I was taking a shower late that night, and while I was in the shower, I wept just a little bit. But it wasn't really full-fledged.
这些照片我想我以前从未见过，这些故事我也从未听过。我回到家，那天深夜洗澡的时候，我在淋浴间哭了一点点。但那并不是真正的彻底大哭。
I kind of feel like I'm emotionally constipated. I guess that's a major part of my problem. People need to express their anger and whatever else they're feeling. I've actually tried to. I've tried because I knew I wanted the release because I knew it would feel good. But I just couldn't do it. Very frustrating.
我感觉自己好像在情绪上便秘了。我想这是我问题的一个重要部分。人们需要表达他们的愤怒以及他们感受到的任何其他东西。我其实试过。我试过，因为我知道我想要那种释放，因为我知道那会感觉很好。但我就是做不到。非常沮丧。
We're in the last nine minutes of this cassette.
磁带只剩下最后九分钟了。
(FAKE WHINY) Oh, there's nine more minutes.
（假装抱怨）哦，还有九分钟。
(FAKE WHINY) I kind of want it over now.
（假装抱怨）我现在只想让它结束。
I can't think of anything else to say. I'm not the kind of guy who can just rattle off his famous last words or big words of advice. Don't have kids unless you had a good relationship with your own parents, I guess, because you can seriously screw them up by saying negative things to them or even neglecting them. Apparently, that's a highly debated cause of sudden infant death syndrome-- not giving your baby enough physical attention.
我想不出还有什么可说的。我不是那种可以随口说出遗言或重大建议的人。我觉得，除非你和自己的父母关系很好，否则别生孩子，因为你可能会通过对他们说负面的话，甚至忽视他们来严重伤害他们。显然，这是一个关于婴儿猝死综合征的高度争议性原因——没有给婴儿足够的身体关注。
One of my psychiatrists said I'm failing to thrive. That's a phrase commonly used for infants who mysteriously die. I'm thinking-- I just kind of amuse myself with the thought that my case is a belated case of sudden infant death syndrome.
我的一个精神科医生说我“发育迟缓”。这是常用于神秘死亡的婴儿的一个词组。我在想——我只是用这个想法来自娱自乐：我的情况是迟来的婴儿猝死综合征。
I don't think my dad failed as a parent, as he worries that he has. I think he did a great job. It's just, along the way, I contracted a disease and it doesn't have a very optimistic or bright prognosis. And not even the best parent can prevent that.
我不认为我父亲作为父母失败了，尽管他担心他失败了。我觉得他做得很好。只是，在这一过程中，我感染了一种疾病，而且它的预后并不乐观或明朗。甚至最好的父母也无法预防这一点。
At the end of editing this story, Brian is still alive, living in the same small town. I don't know if he's getting better or not.
剪辑完这个故事时，布莱恩还活着，住在同一个小镇。我不知道他是否好转了。
Jake Warga. He sent this tape to his friend Brian in 1999 and waited for a reaction. Brian emailed him. He wrote, "How did you learn about the music that you included in the interviews?" He liked some of the pieces, but said they, quote, "Might be a tad overdramatic." And he wanted to know if Jake's computer had a filter that can make him sound less stupid.
杰克·瓦尔加。他于1999年将这盘录音带寄给了他的朋友布莱恩并等待回应。布莱恩给他发了电子邮件。他写道：“你是怎么学到你采访中加入的那些音乐的？”他喜欢其中的一些曲子，但说它们，引用他的话说，“可能有点过度戏剧化了。”他还想知道杰克的电脑是否有过滤器可以让他听起来不那么蠢。
Brian also asked Jake if he had any plans to publish this story. He told Jake that he thought Jake would have an easier time publishing it if he were dead. Nearly two years later, in the spring of 2001, Brian did try to kill himself again, and this time he didn't survive. Jake added this epilogue to the story.
布莱恩还问杰克是否有打算发表这个故事。他告诉杰克，如果他死了，杰克发表这个故事会容易得多。将近两年后的2001年春天，布莱恩确实再次试图自杀，这一次他没能活下来。杰克在这个故事的结尾添加了这段尾声。
On May 9 of this year, Brian's body was found in his room. He had injected himself with a lethal dose of morphine. He was 31 years old. I had sent this tape to Brian sometime after our interview in hopes that, by hearing himself, like looking long and hard into a mirror, he would realize what he was saying, that he would snap out of it. Though he appreciated my efforts, I did not change him. And I came closer to realizing I never could.
今年的5月9日，布莱恩的尸体在他的房间里被发现。他给自己注射了致死剂量的吗啡。他当时31岁。我在我们采访后不久把这盘录音带寄给了布莱恩，希望通过听到自己的声音，就像对着镜子长久且仔细地审视一样，他会意识到自己在说什么，从而从那种状态中走出来。虽然他感谢我的努力，但我没有改变他。我愈发意识到，我永远也做不到。
Brian left packets for a few people, myself included. In them were copies of letters he wrote years before, explaining some of what he felt at the time, and tapes of the interview we did that night. He actually had to make cassette copies for his brother and cousin from the MiniDiscs that I sent him.
布莱恩留下了几个包裹，其中也包括给我的。里面有他几年前写的信的复印件，解释了他当时的一些感受，还有我们那晚采访的录音。他实际上是从我寄给他的迷你光盘中为他的哥哥和表妹制作了磁带备份。
I've had to ask myself now that Brian's dead, why do I want to share this tape? One reason is I want to take something from death, to rob it, for a little while, of the mute it imposes. I also hope that it might help someone who feels like Brian. Or, for friends and family left confused, some sense of closure they may not have had if death were allowed its silence.
布莱恩死后，我不得不问自己，我为什么要分享这盘录音带？一个原因是我想从死亡中夺走一些东西，在那一刻，打破它强加的沉默。我也希望它能帮助那些感觉像布莱恩一样的人。或者，对于那些陷入困惑的朋友和家人，我希望这能带给他们一些如果让死亡保持沉默所无法得到的解脱感。
So Brian, I'm relieved your pains are over. And now it's time for ours to begin. You will be missed.
所以布莱恩，我为你不再痛苦感到欣慰。现在，轮到我们开始痛苦了。我们会想念你的。
Jake Warga. He teaches storytelling at Stanford University. Thanks to Jay Allison and transom.org and KUOW in Seattle, where Jake's story has appeared. If you or somebody you know might need help, the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline is available 24/7 at 1-800-273-TALK. That's 1-800-273-8255.
杰克·瓦尔加。他在斯坦福大学教授叙事。感谢杰·艾莉森、transom.org以及西雅图的KUOW，杰克的故事曾在那儿播出。如果你或你认识的人需要帮助，全国预防自杀生命线提供24/7全天候服务，电话是1-800-273-TALK。即1-800-273-8255。
[MUSIC - "I SEE A DARKNESS" BY BONNIE PRINCE BILLY]
[音乐 - 邦妮·普林斯·比利演唱的《我看到了黑暗》]
Coming up, three magic words that make tough New Yorkers pour out their hearts to strangers. And I'm not talking about "hand it over" or "yes, you've won" or "I love you." Also, your fears listed in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，三个让坚强的纽约人向陌生人倾诉心声的魔法词汇。我说的不是“交出来”、“是的，你赢了”或“我爱你”。此外，当我们的节目继续时，还有来自芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟恐惧列表。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Say Anything, stories about what talking can accomplish and what it cannot accomplish. This show was first broadcast back in 2003. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Battle of Words Versus Fear.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目，“尽管说吧”，讲述谈话能成就什么以及不能成就什么。这个节目于2003年首次播出。我们来到了节目的第二章。第二章，言语与恐惧之战。
Michael Bernard Loggins is in his 50s. He's developmentally disabled. He lives in San Francisco. And he says that there's certain things that he's afraid of, things that just put him on edge. And one day, he felt like he needed to write them down, just to get them out of his system. And so he started writing, numbering each fear. And it quickly got to 10, and then to 20, then to 30 and 40 and 50, till he had 138 of them on paper.
迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯50多岁。他有发育障碍。他住在旧金山。他说有些事情他很害怕，有些事让他感到焦虑。有一天，他觉得需要把它们写下来，把它们排解出去。于是他开始写，为每一个恐惧编号。很快就到了10个，接着是20、30、40、50，直到纸上有了138个恐惧。
The arts program for adults where he did this, a place called Creativity Explored, published this writing as a little handwritten, xeroxed zine called, "Fears of Your Life." A few years later, Michael found that there were more fears to tame by turning them into words, and he put out a part two, a sequel titled, "Fears of Your Life, a Whole Brand New One." This one listed 45 fears. Michael gave us permission to excerpt the two books, which we do now. Actor Tom Wright is our reader.
他完成这些作品的成人艺术项目，一个叫“创意探索”的地方，将这些文字出版成了一本手工制作、复印的小册子，名为《你生命中的恐惧》。几年后，迈克尔发现还有更多的恐惧需要通过转化为文字来驯服，他出版了第二部分，续集名为《你生命中的恐惧，一个全新的版本》。这一本列出了45个恐惧。迈克尔授权我们节选这两本书，现在我们就来读一下。演员汤姆·莱特是我们的朗读者。
Fear of hospitals and needles. Fear of school and dentists. Fear of noises and bumps in the middle of the night. Fear of doors when they slams. Fear of toys that come on by itself without anyone touching it.
害怕医院和针头。害怕学校和牙医。害怕午夜的噪音和碰撞声。害怕关门时的巨响。害怕没人碰却会自动开启的玩具。
Fear of being caught with another woman after cheating on your wife. Fear of being in wrong places at the wrong time. Fear of dropping your soda as it hit the ground and fizz on you. Fear of tall giraffe. Fear of some birds. Fear of being different.
害怕出轨被妻子当场抓住。害怕在错误的时间出现在错误的地点。害怕汽水掉在地上喷到自己身上。害怕长颈鹿。害怕某些鸟。害怕与众不同。
I fear that those TV people would take off my favorite cartoon, The Rugrats, off the air and wouldn't be able to watch them anymore for a long, long, long time. Please let well enough alone. Please don't take my Rugrats cartoon off the air because I love that cartoon. Let there be a possibility that life with the Rugrats stays put, means leave my Rugrats cartoon on TV, Michael said.
我害怕那些电视节目组会把我最喜欢的动画片《淘气小兵兵》停播，那样我就不能再看它们了，很长、很长、很长的时间。请顺其自然吧。请不要停播我的《淘气小兵兵》动画片，因为我爱那部动画片。让《淘气小兵兵》的生活能持续下去吧，这意味着把我的动画片留在电视上，迈克尔说。
Fear if you put things that doesn't belongs in your ears and you bust the drums that's are in your ears, it liable to run you deaf, where you can't hear anything at all. You wouldn't be able to hear cars when they're coming at you. That can be a frightening and very horrible situation to happen to you if you had an occurrence in real life, especially if you comes involved in it. Can you get hit by cars if you can't hear them?
害怕如果你把不该放的东西塞进耳朵，弄坏了耳膜，那可能会让你变聋，什么也听不见。你将听不到迎面而来的汽车声。如果现实生活中发生了这种情况，那可能是一种可怕而糟糕的情况，特别是如果你卷入其中的话。如果你听不见汽车，你会被撞到吗？
Michael is afraid and frightening and fearful when Andrea Scheer goes away for a very, very, very long, long, long, long vacational trips in order to go traveling all over the world, almost like different places and different cities and countries to visit people in her own image and own language. He afraid Andrea Scheer would come back to San Francisco, California, with all different accents and won't be able to speak Michael's English, or not be able to understand his words that he's telling her, like Merry Christmas.
当安德烈亚·希尔为了去世界各地旅行，去不同的地方、城市和国家以她自己的形象和语言探访人们，去进行漫长的度假旅行时，迈克尔感到害怕、惊慌和忧虑。他害怕安德烈亚·希尔回到加利福尼亚的旧金山时，带着各种不同的口音，无法讲迈克尔的英语，或者听不懂他说的词，比如“圣诞快乐”。
I'm afraid and fearful that pigeons don't know right from wrong to not go out into the street. They don't have the kind of memory as we humans does to know what to do and what shall not do. They must don't know the danger of their lives are being jeopardized. And they must don't know what can definitely happen to them to humans' knowledges and sense. They land just anywhere they can find a land on surface.
我害怕并忧虑鸽子不知道对错，不知道不去街上。它们没有我们人类那样的记忆，不知道该做什么、不该做什么。它们肯定不知道自己的生命正处于危险之中。它们肯定不知道对于人类的知识和感知来说会发生什么。它们随地降落在任何能着陆的表面上。
Fear of sharks. Fear of giant man. Fear of gorilla. Fear of Godzilla. Fear of tall woman. Fear of killer whales. Fear of dinosaurs bird. Fear of invisible man. Fear of Blob. Fear that, if I go into the library and I happens to get like seven or eight books and I happens to find a place in the library that I would get a lot of comfortable and begin reading in those seven or eight books, but one book at a time, and I start to read and somehow, my voice and mind start to get from low to high and, thinking that there weren't anyone elses reading theirs, and I look over and the people in the library, and I get fearful and I'll say, "Oops, sorry."
害怕鲨鱼。害怕巨人。害怕大猩猩。害怕哥斯拉。害怕高个女人。害怕虎鲸。害怕恐龙鸟。害怕隐形人。害怕史莱姆。害怕如果我走进图书馆，顺手拿了七八本书，又在图书馆里找了个舒服的地方开始读这七八本书，但一次只能读一本，我开始读了，不知怎么地，我的声音和心思开始从低变高，以为没人在读他们的书，我抬头看一看图书馆里的人，我感到害怕，然后说：“喔，抱歉。”
If your friends are people that you are with and you hear them making decision about what they decided that they are going to steal expensive and very valuable merchandise out of the department stores and don't care less, you say, I am out of here. Bye bye. I'm not getting caught in your crazy schemes. I'm not your stealer partner. I'm just your friend. It's going to trouble, and it's on your head, not mine. I'm not going to participate in stealing with you, so leave me out of your crazy schemes, especially if it involve Oreo cookies and other stuff, hot stuff. Fear of me getting in trouble just as well.
如果你的朋友是你正在相处的人，你听到他们决定要去百货商店偷昂贵且非常有价值的商品，而且毫不在意，你会说，我走人了。再见。我才不会被卷入你们疯狂的计划。我不是你们的偷窃伙伴。我只是你们的朋友。这是自找麻烦，后果由你们自己承担，不是我。我不会参与你们的偷窃，所以别把我扯进你们疯狂的计划，尤其是如果这涉及到奥利奥饼干和其他东西，那种烫手的东西。害怕我自己也惹上麻烦。
It's very scary and fearfully to be sleeping in your bed in the middle of the night whenever there's a telephone right beside the bed on you left near the door you once enter and exit out. You are sleeping. The telephone rang and scared the living life out of you in the middle of the night. Who is this calling at this hour of the night?
在午夜时分躺在床上，当床左侧靠近出口门的地方有部电话时，那是非常可怕的。你正在睡觉。电话响了，在深夜把你吓得魂飞魄散。在这个时间点打电话来的是谁？
Fear of a blasted music on the radio, where you are not aware that the volume is turned up. Fear of rolling downhill backward. Fear of foghorn. Fear of getting hugged by somebody you don't like. There's Los Angeles fears. Fear of getting hit over the head when you carry lots of dough with you, or bucks.
害怕收音机里的巨大音乐声，你还没意识到音量被调大了。害怕向后滚下山坡。害怕雾笛声。害怕被你不喜欢的人拥抱。洛杉矶有很多恐惧。害怕在你随身携带大量现金或钞票时被敲头。
Fear is like this. Someone like a woman that you grab a hold of her hand in going down the escalator, when of a sudden, you happens to be holding a stranger hand, not realizing that she isn't your mother is scary. Fear that if you put too much of toilet paper in the toilet bowl, it will run over and get all over the floor and on you and on someone else, too. It would leak from upstairs to the next floor below.
恐惧是这样的。就像你拉着一个女人的手走自动扶梯时，突然之间，你握住的是一个陌生人的手，才意识到她不是你妈妈，这很可怕。害怕如果你在马桶里放太多的卫生纸，它会溢出来，弄得到处都是，弄在地上，也弄在你和别人身上。它会从楼上漏到下一层楼。
I am afraid someday I liable to get lost inside Children's Hospital if I'm not all so familiar with that place yet. It's going to take some time to get used to it. Fearfully of that great big, humongous Children's Hospital there ever would be to Michael's knowledge. Good that Michael's sister is driving him up there on Tuesday, January 15, 2002. Even though she's with him, she can easily get lost, too. Bad situation to tangled up in, especially if you that person has an appointment at 10:45 AM in the morning. Michael Bernard Loggins does.
我担心有一天我可能会在儿童医院迷路，如果我还不太熟悉那个地方的话。得花点时间适应它。对迈克尔所知的有史以来最大、最庞大的儿童医院感到恐惧。迈克尔的姐姐在2002年1月15日星期二开车带他去那里，这很好。即使她和他在一起，她也很容易迷路。陷入这种糟糕的情况中，尤其是如果那个人在上午10点45分有预约。迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯就有。
Michael fear that if his teacher Francis doesn't put away Michael's Top Ramen noodles up in the desk drawer that Douglas will see it and he'll liable to want to take it, and he'll happen to eat up Michael Bernard Loggins' noodles himself. And Michael Bernard Loggins would be out of luck, but he would have to go home tonight and bring back to school another pack of noodles to eat himself so that wouldn't ever, ever happened with that Douglas eat up noodle story.
迈克尔担心如果他的老师弗朗西斯不把他的合味道方便面放进书桌抽屉里，道格拉斯会看到，他可能会想拿走，而且他会把迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯的方便面自己吃掉。而迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯就会倒霉，他今晚必须回家，带另一包方便面回学校自己吃，这样那种道格拉斯吃掉方便面的故事就不会发生。
It would be very fearful if I reached up on top shelf trying to reach for a nice thicker-covered dictionary book and not ask for help from someone and the books come off the shelf and make lots of noises and the people gets angry at me and don't understand that I had want help, but I were afraid to ask for it. And they'd be a jerk or a creep, as Hope tells me. And people say that I'll have to pay for the shelf, and I get in lots of trouble behind it, says Michael.
如果我伸手去够顶架上的那本厚皮字典，而没有向别人求助，书架上的书掉下来发出巨大的噪音，人们对我生气，却不理解我其实想要帮助，只是害怕去要求，那会非常令人恐惧。他们会像“希望”告诉我的那样，是个混蛋或讨厌鬼。人们说我必须赔偿书架，我会被卷入很多麻烦，迈克尔说。
Fear of being with a friend that you have recently met start to take you places with him and you doesn't know him all that well. You didn't know that he were going to bring you fear and lots of trouble your way. Someone you doesn't know all that well starts to carry you in the store to buy you and him something to eat and drink, and all of the sudden, something very fishy starts to happen. Like for instance, your friend that you are with could be up to trouble and whoever with him could be heading in for trouble, as well, especially if a friend of yours could be bringing you trouble by stealing a big package of Oreo cookie.
害怕与刚认识的朋友在一起，他开始带你去一些地方，而你对他并不了解。你不知道他会给你带来恐惧和很多麻烦。一个你并不了解的人开始带你去商店给你和他也买点吃喝的，突然之间，一些非常可疑的事情开始发生。比如，你同行的朋友可能在惹麻烦，而和他在一起的任何人也可能惹上麻烦，尤其是如果你的朋友通过偷一大包奥利奥饼干来给你带来麻烦的话。
People are fearful of me, which I wonder, is they think I'm all that terrible? Or I'm thinking that they think I'm not human at all, because when they sit next to me, then they get back up and move away from me. I may be a stranger, but that doesn't make me a created monster or something like that. People aren't humans. They act like ignorance dogs with their tail in back of their legs or in between their middle bodies their legs. They don't think whose feeling they hurt at all. They just do it, no consideration for whatsoever. People don't think about how they hurt my feelings or don't give a hoot. They don't give a crap.
人们对我感到恐惧，我很好奇，他们认为我真有那么糟糕吗？或者我想他们认为我根本不是人类，因为当他们坐在我旁边时，他们会起身走开。我可能是一个陌生人，但这并不会让我变成创造出来的怪物之类的东西。人们不是人类。他们表现得像无知的狗，尾巴夹在腿中间或后腿之间。他们根本不在乎自己伤害了谁的感情。他们就这样做了，完全不顾他人。人们不考虑他们如何伤害我的感情，也不在乎。他们根本不在乎。
Fear of you never knowing you were going to lose your mother is very sad and scary experience you have to face and learn from. And you wonder why she has to die. I love her. And I had loved her once while she were alive, especially if she was the mother that raised you and the others through birth. And you only wish that you could have done all you can to help save her life. There going to be a worse times and hard times for Michael Bernard Loggins and his sisters and brothers, too, especially when Mother's Day comes. Afraid this is the last thing that ever occur to me.
害怕你永远不知道自己会失去母亲，这是一种你必须面对并从中学习的非常悲伤和可怕的经历。你会纳闷为什么她不得不死。我爱她。当她还活着的时候，我爱过她，尤其是如果她是那个把你和其他人抚养长大的母亲。你只希望你能尽你所能去救她的命。对迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯和他的姐妹兄弟们来说，会有更糟的时期和艰难时刻，尤其是在母亲节的时候。害怕这是最后一件发生在我身上的事情。
Excerpts from Michael Bernard Loggins' two xeroxed zines, "Fears of Your Life," Parts One and Two, read first by Tom Wright, an actor in Los Angeles. Michael writes and makes art in San Francisco. To get your own copy of these amazing books or to find out more about the arts program where they were made, visit the website of Creativity Explored, creativityexplored.org.
迈克尔·伯纳德·洛金斯两本复印小册子《你生命中的恐惧》第一部分和第二部分的节选，首先由洛杉矶演员汤姆·莱特朗读。迈克尔在旧金山从事写作和艺术创作。想拥有自己的这些精彩书籍，或了解更多关于它们创作地的艺术项目，请访问“创意探索”网站 creativityexplored.org。
[MUSIC - "HE'S REALLY SAYING SOMETHING" BY BANANARAMA]
[音乐 - 香蕉女郎演唱的《他真的说出了什么》]
Act Three, When the City Opens Its Big Mouth. For months, Liz Berry and Bill Wetzel have been going out in the streets, seven days a week, 12 or 13 hours a day, in any kind of weather, with a handmade sign that says, "Talk to me."
第三章，当城市张开大嘴。几个月来，利兹·贝瑞和比尔·韦策尔一直走在街头，每周七天，每天12或13个小时，无论什么天气，拿着一块手工制作的牌子，上面写着：“跟我聊聊。”
Hello.
你好。
What's this?
这是什么？
Just being friendly.
只是表达友好。
Huh?
啊？
In a way, it's a relief to see just how wary people are of being scammed. Nearly every person who approaches them asks the same question in one form or another. Are you taking money? Are you with some organization? Are you doing this for TV or something? In other words, as one Chinese woman put it--
在某种程度上，看到人们对被骗的警惕性有多高，这真是一种宽慰。几乎每一个接近他们的人都会以某种方式提出同样的问题。你们在收钱吗？你们属于什么组织吗？你们是在为电视或其他什么东西做这个吗？换句话说，正如一位中国女士所言——
Who are you and what for?
你们是谁，为了什么？
I'm Bill, and that's Liz, and it's just the two of us.
我是比尔，她是利兹，就我们两个人。
Here they are, people who decided that it might be nice if strangers would just interact a little more. And they were going to take their matters into their own hands to see that it happen, even though it pays no money, even though it means camping on people's couches, even though they end up acting like cheerful customer service representatives to a largely indifferent world, one exhausting hour after another.
在这里，他们决定如果陌生人能多交流一点会很好。他们决定亲自动手来看看能不能实现，即使这没有任何报酬，即使这意味着要睡在别人的沙发上，即使他们最终在一个很大程度上冷漠的世界里表现得像个开朗的客服代表，一个小时接一个小时地精疲力竭。
We just put up this sign and anything people want to talk about, we'll go with it.
我们只是立起这个牌子，人们想谈什么，我们就跟他们谈什么。
Sign?
牌子？
Liz is 25. Bill is 23. But they each use the kind of vernacular that you'd expect from an 80-year-old woman. They call men fellas. And instead of using the word ass or bum to describe the part of the body that you sit on, they favor the word patootie.
利兹25岁，比尔23岁。但他们每个人都使用那种你可能从80岁老太太口中听到的方言。他们称男人为“小伙子”。而且，比起用那个词来形容你坐着的身体部位，他们更偏爱用“屁股”这个词。
They smile easily. They look young and vulnerable and almost overwhelmingly earnest. That kind of thing either works for you, or it doesn't. And for them, apparently it does. People talk to them. The sign does its job. Two plainclothes cops approach, and the one in the wraparound sunglasses talks first.
他们容易微笑。他们看起来年轻、脆弱，几乎极其真诚。这种事情要么对你有用，要么没用。而对他们来说，显然有用。人们和他们说话。牌子起了作用。两个便衣警察走近，戴着环绕式墨镜的那个先开了口。
This girl I've been going out with for two years just got engaged to some dude after dating him for four weeks.
我谈了两年的女朋友在和另一个人约会四个星期后就订婚了。
Did you think she was just spending your time? Did you think she was stringing you along? Do you think she didn't love you?
你觉得她是在浪费你的时间吗？你觉得她一直在吊着你吗？你觉得她不爱你吗？
Yeah, sure, for like the last six months. Yeah. Nice, right?
是的，当然，大概有六个月了。很好，对吧？
Did you know?
你知道吗？
No. I had no idea. Nope.
不。我一点都不知道。不。
In the course of this one day in New York City, Liz and Bill chat with a teenager from LaGuardia High School who was all excited about the fake country she and her friends had made up. There was a drunk guy carrying bags full of brand new computer equipment. He talked about how much money he's making.
在纽约市的这一天里，利兹和比尔与拉瓜迪亚高中的一个青少年聊了天，她对她和朋友们编造的假想国非常兴奋。有个醉醺醺的家伙拎着装满全新电脑设备的袋子。他谈到了他赚了多少钱。
A woman who just quit the AmeriCorps program hours before because it seemed too dangerous, and they wouldn't even give her a phone. There was a guy in Harlem who fixed up two of the patients in the optometrist's office where he works. A woman who was mad at the teacher who hit her son in school. A well-dressed man who explained the intricacies of estate tax assessment.
还有一位女士，几小时前刚辞去了美国志愿队的工作，因为那看起来太危险了，他们甚至不给她配一部电话。还有哈勒姆的一个家伙，他在工作的眼科诊所修复了两位病人的视力。一位对在学校打她儿子的老师感到愤怒的女士。一位衣着考究的男士，他解释了遗产税评估的错综复杂。
And there was this guy, who walked up to Liz and Bill right after being let go from his job.
还有一个刚被解雇后走向利兹和比尔的家伙。
They brought me into an office and they just said, "As you know, things have been very slow, and I really don't know how to tell you this. I mean, you've been great. It's not a firing. It's purely economic-based." But I feel like-- have you ever been laid off or fired?
他们把我叫进办公室，只是说：“你知道，情况一直很缓慢，我真的不知道该怎么告诉你。我的意思是，你一直很棒。这不是解雇。这纯粹是出于经济原因。”但我感觉——你们曾经被解雇或辞退过吗？
Yes.
是的。
You know that blank feeling you get right here? It's just like, oh, my god.
你知道你这里会有的那种空白感吧？就像，噢，天哪。
Do you have any kind of savings? Are you in a rent-stabilized place?
你有存款吗？你住在租金稳定的地方吗？
Yeah. No, I'm in a rent-stabilized place.
是的。不，我住在租金稳定的地方。
As conversationalists, Bill and Liz are perfectly fine, no better or worse than you and me. Mostly what they do is keep the ball rolling. Watching all this for several hours, it makes you start to see everyone on the street differently. Everyone starts to seem like he or she could suddenly burst into a story. A whole city seems filled with people who need to get something off their chests.
作为谈话者，比尔和利兹表现得非常好，不比你我更好或更差。他们主要做的是保持对话进行下去。观察这一切几个小时，让你开始以不同的眼光看待街上的每个人。每个人看起来都好像突然会吐露一个故事。整座城市似乎挤满了需要倾诉心声的人。
At this point, it's also, I want just some more stability in my life. And my birthday's next week. I'm going to be 39 years old.
在这一点上，我还想要生活中的稳定感。我下周生日。我就要39岁了。
At the end of day, a man talks to them for three hours. Three hours. Mostly about a girlfriend that he lost who he can't get over, but also about the war and the time, years ago, that he tried to kill himself. By the end, it was 1:00 in the morning and he offered Liz and Bill $100, which they turned down. Liz was still full of energy and completely cheery. It seemed like she could go for another three hours. But it was late and the streets were clearing, and it was time to go home.
一天结束时，一个男人和他们聊了三个小时。三个小时。主要关于他失去的那个无法释怀的女友，但也谈到了战争，谈到多年前他试图自杀的那次经历。到最后，已经是凌晨1点了，他给了利兹和比尔100美元，他们拒绝了。利兹依然精力充沛，完全兴致勃勃。看起来她可以再聊三个小时。但天色已晚，街道也空了，是时候回家了。
[MUSIC - "TALK TO ME" BY HEATHER NOVA]
[音乐 - 海瑟·诺娃演唱的《跟我聊聊》]
Act Four, Wedding Bells and Telephone Bells. We end our program today with two brief case studies of situations where the words for something don't even matter, where it's not about the words at all. We begin with this one from Elizabeth Gilbert.
第四章，婚礼的钟声与电话的铃声。我们以两个简短的案例研究结束今天的节目，探讨语言在某些情况下根本不重要，因为这根本与言语无关。我们从伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特带来的这一个开始。
My friend Kevin once attended a wedding where he heard the world's most inappropriate wedding toast. The toast began inauspiciously enough. The best man stood up during the meal, clinked his knife against the crystal, and the other guests all quieted down.
我的朋友凯文曾参加过一个婚礼，在那里他听到了世界上最不合时宜的婚礼祝酒词。祝酒词的开头还算平稳。伴郎在用餐期间站起来，用刀轻敲水晶杯，其他宾客都安静了下来。
"I was thinking on the airplane ride here about what I was going to say today about Danny and Joyce," the best man began. "And all I could think at first was what a happy day today is." Good enough start. But then this speech took an interesting turn. "And I realized that what I really wanted to talk about this afternoon is jury duty."
“我在飞往这里的飞机上一直在想今天关于丹尼和乔伊斯我要说些什么，”伴郎开始说。“起初我脑子里想到的只有今天是一个多么快乐的日子。”开场不错。但随后这段演讲发生了有趣的转折。“然后我意识到，今天下午我真正想聊的是陪审团义务。”
"Now, I don't know how many of you have ever served on a jury," he went on. "But it's a fascinating process. I was just on a jury last year for the first time in my life, and I learned a lot about myself and about the legal system. It was a pretty serious case, too. It was actually a murder trial. It was very tragic. It was this old man who got killed. Very sad. He was getting money out of an ATM in the middle of the day and some gang kids came up and robbed him and shot him right in the face."
“现在，我不知道你们有多少人担任过陪审员，”他接着说。“但这是一个迷人的过程。去年我人生中第一次当陪审员，我对自己和法律制度学到了很多。那也是一个相当严重的案件。实际上是一起谋杀案审判。非常悲惨。是一个老人在大白天从ATM机取钱时被一群帮派孩子抢劫并直接朝脸上开了枪。”
By now, many of the wedding guests were lowering their champagne glasses gently back down to the table. "It was a cut-and-dry case, really," he went on. "There were plenty of witnesses, and the forensic evidence pointed straight to one kid as the shooter. The kid was definitely guilty. But here's the thing. It was actually a capital offense. And my jury had to decide whether or not to give this kid the death penalty."
此时，许多婚礼宾客正轻轻地将香槟杯放回桌上。“那真是一个证据确凿的案件，”他继续说道。“有大量的证人，法医证据直接指向其中一个孩子是枪手。那孩子绝对是有罪的。但问题是。这实际上是死刑案件。我的陪审团不得不决定是否判处这个孩子死刑。”
"Now, I don't know if any of you have ever had to decide whether somebody should live or die, but it's emotionally intense. We all knew the kid was guilty, but the death penalty is nothing to take lightly. In the end, though, we decided yes, this kid needs to die. And we sent him to his death."
“现在，我不知道你们是否有人曾经不得不决定某人该生还是该死，但这在情感上非常强烈。我们都知道那孩子有罪，但死刑不是可以轻率对待的事情。不过最终，我们决定是的，这个孩子必须死。我们将他送上了死路。”
The tent was silent. The bride, ashen. The best man took a moment to compose himself and concluded, "That was probably the worst day of my life. And I got to thinking about it on the plane because that day was nothing like today, which is a happy day. A really happy day. So here's to Danny and Joyce." Thus concluded the toast.
帐篷里一片寂静。新娘脸色煞白。伴郎花了一点时间平复情绪，总结道：“那可能是我一生中最糟糕的一天。我在飞机上一直在想这件事，因为那一天和今天完全不同，今天是快乐的一天。真正快乐的一天。所以，敬丹尼和乔伊斯。”祝酒词至此结束。
I've pondered the meaning of this story for years, and ultimately, I've decided that I get it. I've heard it said before that the human psyche cannot always tell the difference between good events and bad events. All we can feel is the tremor of the earth. Which is what happened to our best man, I believe. He was so overcome by happiness for his friend and he was so out of touch with his emotions that he couldn't express that happiness appropriately. All he could do was remember the last time he had felt so moved by something, and so he tried to express that.
我多年来一直在思考这个故事的含义，最终，我觉得我懂了。我以前听人说过，人类的心理并不总能区分好事和坏事。我们所能感受到的只有大地的震颤。我相信这就是发生在我们这位伴郎身上的事情。他被朋友的快乐深深打动，以至于他与自己的情绪脱节，无法适当地表达那种快乐。他所能做的只是回忆起上一次他因某事而如此感动时的情景，所以他试图表达出来。
Sure, there's nothing parallel about an old man getting shot in the face and a dear friend getting married-- unless, of course, you measure human emotion by the weight, in which case, the two events carry exactly the same impact. Which is to say that I think I finally understand what the best man was trying to convey that afternoon. And I raise my glass to the poor guy for his valiant and hopeless attempt to celebrate.
当然，老人被枪击脸部和挚友结婚之间没有任何相似之处——除非，你以重量来衡量人类情感，在这种情况下，这两个事件带来的冲击力完全相同。也就是说，我想我终于明白了伴郎那天下午想要表达的内容。我举杯向这家伙致意，为了他那徒劳且毫无希望的庆祝尝试。
Liz Gilbert is the author of many books, including most recently, Big Magic. Her story first appeared on a website that doesn't exist anymore but was called otherpeoplesstories.com.
利兹·吉尔伯特是许多书的作者，包括最近出版的《大魔法》。她的故事最初出现在一个已经不存在但名为otherpeoplesstories.com的网站上。
Well, now we move onto our next example of wordless communication. Our very last example today from Jonathan Goldstein.
好的，现在我们转向下一个无言交流的例子。我们今天的最后一个例子来自乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。
Hettie lives in the same building she grew up in, and I live with her. We're in an apartment two floors up from her dad. He's 78 years old and doesn't want to bother climbing up the stairs every time he wants her, so he ends up usually just calling her on the phone. He calls anywhere from 20 to 30 times a day. The one thing he never wants is conversation.
赫蒂住在他长大的那栋楼里，我和她住在一起。我们住在楼上两层，离她爸爸不远。他78岁了，不想每次想要找她时都费力爬楼梯，所以他通常最后只是给她打电话。他每天打20到30次电话。他唯一不想要的就是谈话。
Sometimes he calls to ask Hettie what time it is because he's too tired to get up and look for himself. Sometimes he calls to see what she's having for dinner. But most of the time, he calls and doesn't say a thing. Hettie picks up the phone and only hears classical music playing and she knows it's her dad with his kitchen radio on. Sometimes I'll walk into the living room and Hettie will be watching TV with the telephone cupped to her ear, not saying a word, and I know she's on the phone with her dad, and that, three floors down, he's sitting, watching TV just as silently.
有时他打电话问赫蒂几点了，因为他太累了，起不来自己看。有时他打电话看她晚餐吃什么。但大部分时间，他打电话过来却什么也不说。赫蒂拿起电话只能听到古典音乐在播放，她知道那是她爸爸开了厨房里的收音机。有时我走进客厅，赫蒂正看着电视，电话捂在耳边，一言不发，我知道她正跟她爸爸通电话，而在三层楼下，他也同样安静地坐着看电视。
When our line is in use, the voice mail picks up. Hettie's father will leave a dozen messages in a row. The way we know it's him is that there are no words, just the click of the phone. After about 10 minutes, the fact that he can't get through starts to drive him crazy, so he walks down to the buzzers by the building's main door and buzzes our apartment. The way he sees it, why should he have to walk up two flights of stairs when he could just walk down one?
当我们线路占用时，语音信箱会自动接入。赫蒂的父亲会接连留下十几条留言。我们知道是他，是因为没有话语，只有电话的点击声。大约10分钟后，打不进电话的事实开始让他抓狂，所以他会走到楼内正门处的门铃旁，按响我们的公寓。在他看来，既然可以只走一层楼梯，为什么非要走两层呢？
The buzzer is like an amplified dentist drill. And sometimes, when you're quiet or deep in thought, the suddenness of it is like being goosed by something cold and metallic. It is the kind of sound that rats in lab experiments come to associate with a terrible, perhaps fatal, error. When we hear the buzzer, we get off the internet or the telephone so that he could call. Even now it could buzz, you think to yourself. Or even now.
那个门铃声就像被放大的牙医电钻。有时，当你安静或陷入深思时，那突如其来的声音就像被某种冰冷的金属物体戳了一下。这是实验室老鼠会将其与某种可怕的、甚至是致命的错误联系起来的那种声音。当我们听到门铃声，我们会退出互联网或电话，以便他可以打进来。即使现在它也可能响，你会这样想。或者即使是现在。
One day, I didn't get off the internet quick enough, so he went back down to the buzzer, and this time, he just leaned on it. I got off the line and Hettie phoned him. He wasn't answering. She yelled down the stairs, but still he would not stop. He was making a point. I am not exaggerating when I say that he kept the buzzer going for several minutes straight. And after a while, you could hear layered fluctuations and subtle pitch blends. He was like Yoko Ono on that thing.
有一天，我没来得及迅速退出网络，所以他又回到门铃处，这一次，他只是靠在上面一直按着。我退出了线路，赫蒂给他打了过去。他不接。她对着楼梯大喊，但他还是不停手。他是在强调某点。我不夸张地说，他连续按了好几分钟门铃。过了一会儿，你可以听到层叠的波动和微妙的音调混合。他简直就像那个东西上的小野洋子。
Hettie got on a chair and hit the box above the door with a hammer. The buzzing stopped. A few minutes later, her father called. "What was so important?" Hettie asked. Her father was quiet. Finally, he asked her if she knew what night the Oscars were on. Hettie told him that he had gone too far.
赫蒂站在椅子上用锤子砸向门上的盒子。嗡嗡声停止了。几分钟后，她父亲打来电话。“什么事这么重要？”赫蒂问。她父亲沉默了。最后，他问她知不知道奥斯卡颁奖典礼是哪晚。赫蒂告诉他，他太过分了。
It made Hettie's father sad that our doorbell was gone. He suggested that he and Hettie get walkie-talkies. I imagined them both sitting in their separate kitchens, each eating a sandwich, and in between long silences, one of them uttering the occasional 10-4. Hettie refused the offer. "Fine," he said. "From now on, I'll just go down into the basement and turn off the building's power two times really fast. I noticed where they keep the main switch the other day. That'll be the signal for you to free up the line."
门铃坏了让赫蒂的父亲感到难过。他建议他和赫蒂买对讲机。我想象着他们各自坐在厨房里，一人吃着三明治，在长久的沉默中，偶尔有一方说一句“收到”。赫蒂拒绝了。 “好吧，”他说，“从现在起，我就下到地下室，把整栋楼的电源连续切断两次。我那天注意到他们把总开关放在哪里了。那将是给你的信号，让你腾出线路。”
Hettie told him that that would be the signal for her to move out. Now her father just comes up and knocks. He knocks in a particular way that I think is supposed to be a secret code. Often, after Hettie has answered the door, he just stands there in the doorway, looking at her uncertainly, sort of put upon that now that he's got her attention. He actually has to come up with something to say.
赫蒂告诉他，那将是她搬出去的信号。现在她父亲只是走上来敲门。他敲门的方式很特别，我想那应该是一个秘密代码。通常，赫蒂开门后，他只是站在门口，不确定地看着她，好像一旦引起了她的注意，他反而不知所措。他实际上不得不找点什么话说。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the podcast Heavyweight from Gimlet Media.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是Gimlet Media旗下播客《重量级》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "KNOCK THREE TIMES" BY TONY ORLANDO AND DAWN]
[音乐 - 托尼·奥兰多和黎明合唱团演唱的《敲三下》]
Well, this rerun episode of our program was produced by Starlee Kine and me, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, and David Kestenbaum. Matt Tierney is our technical director. Production help from Diane Wu.
嗯，我们节目的这一集重播由斯塔莉·凯恩和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔和戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆参与。马特·蒂尔尼是我们的技术指导。生产援助来自黛安·吴。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who begs you, who implores you.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他恳求你，他乞求你。
Please don't take my Rugrats cartoon off the air because I love that cartoon.
请不要停播我的《淘气小兵兵》动画片，因为我爱那部动画片。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - TONY ORLANDO AND DAWN, "KNOCK THREE TIMES"]
[音乐 - 托尼·奥兰多和黎明合唱团演唱的《敲三下》]